ans une casquette de cyclistes à celui
que l'on n'arrête plus laurent jalabert
vainqueur cet après-midi du critérium
international après ses victoires dans
paris-nice et milan san remo laurent
jalabert qui savoure d'autant plus ses
succès qu'il revient de loin après son
accident du tour de france l'année
dernière thierry clopeau laurent
jalabert a dû se croire maudit à
l'arrivée de la deuxième étape ce matin
le coureur de ncr failli revivre une
bien mauvaise aventure une petite
collision avec un spectateur
heureusement sans gravité malgré cet
incident de parcours cela ne l'a pas
empêché de remporter cet après-midi le
critérium international
jalabert en jaune c'est toute la france
du vélo qui se met à rêver une image
entretenir jusqu'au mois de juillet
jusqu'au tour de france
une fois le classique d'avril terminer
mon principal objectif sera le tour de
france est alors à ce moment là tout ce
que je vais faire ce soir en fonction du
tour donc à ce moment là je commence à y
penser
pourtant laurent jalabert revient de
loin le 3 juillet dernier à armentières
il percute un policier dans le sprint
final
la chute est terrible violence et les
dégâts pour jalabert sont considérables
cage thoracique enfoncée
plusieurs fractures de la mâchoire et
des bleus un peu partout sur son lit
d'hôpital jalabert souffre mais ne doute
pas que c'est une partie de ma vie et
laurent jalabert à force de courage va
se donner les moyens de cette ambition
il ya trois semaines c'était paris nice
la première grande course par étapes de
la saison
la première victoire du revenant plus
fort encore une semaine plus tard il
remporte sa première grande classique
milan san remo devant l'italien
fondriest jalabert rejoint l'or est plus
grand
sa victoire aujourd'hui au critérium
international de la route est carrément
à un exploit historique jamais un
coureur n'avait remporté ses trois
courses d'affilée
bien sûr on commence à penser très fort
au tour de france le tour qui lui a valu
tant de souffrance mais qui n'a pas fait
lui porter malheur en 92 avec une
victoire d'étape en prime jalabert avait
endossé sur les champs-elysées le
maillot vert du classement par points
avec de nouvelles qualités de grimpeur
qu'on ne soupçonnait pas il peut
désormais rêver d'un maillot d'une autre
couleur le jaune il a si bien